[Music]  fighting in order to live  and living to fight  [Music]  that's the way of our world  ionios  tell me  what would possess you to side with them  we're fighting because there are enemies  to kill i refuse to believe you're him  i knew it i saw this coming you are  you're not enemies now fine for you  isn't it all that time you've got you  could try try to move forwards again how  can our lives be so snuffing little do  you they're not your friends anymore  they're his few  sword match  the land pierced by a great sword  it's the only way you're gonna defeat  the real enemy  whatever life is lost i won't let you  solder it all alone what could filling  up these flickering clocks in our eyes  it will never replace the predatory  block the flame clock it has to go  uroboros are bore this world they must  be erased without a trace  [Music]  you